hi there Steve coffin here how do we get
to speak in a language I'm sure those of
you who have been following my youtube
channel and who have read my blog and
are on link realize that I believe that
input based learning is very important I
believe in developing a large passive
vocabulary focusing on comprehension a
lot of listening and reading I believe
that you know a large passive vocabulary
is your key sort of foundation for
becoming fluent in a language but fluent
means speaking so how do you get how do
you convert that passive knowledge into
the ability to speak well and I
regularly hear from people who say that
they can read well and understand but
they can't speak well I want to get into
that subject today first of all though
very often when people say that they
read well that doesn't necessarily mean
that they read enough I think we should
all get to the stage where we can
actually read novels in another language
I mean that's ideal now not everyone has
the luxury you know to spend the time to
get to where they can read novels so but
let's get now to this central issue of
how do we start speaking and how do we
become good at speaking in and what we
can what can we do to speed up the
process first thing is you have to kind
of be willing to break through what I
call the stupidity barrier it's like a
sound barrier but it's the barrier of
sounding stupid you have to be willing
to sound stupid and you sound stupid
more to yourself than to the person
listening to you because you're aware of
the fact that you're mumbling and
mangling the language and not speaking
it as well as you would like and not you
know your
thoughts and the feelings aren't coming
out the way you would like and it's kind
of discouraging and at times it seems as
if you've made a bit of progress in the
next time you go to speak you feel as if
you've slipped and become worse again
and and so I mean and and all I can say
is that everyone experiences this I
experienced it and you know we have that
first exhilarating feeling as as we're
able to say a few things in the language
and then to get from there to where we
are generally genuinely fluent and able
to express ourselves is just a long long
road and we have to be willing to put
ourselves in the situation where we
stumble and say the wrong thing and we
have to in many cases we have to trust
our instincts and trust our intuition
just go for it and say it and if it
sounds stupid it doesn't matter if we
get too hung up about trying to speak
perfectly that often inhibits us so so
basically again just to review what I've
said there was I will still believe in a
major emphasis on input lots of reading
getting to the point if possible where
you can read novels make sure you can
understand because that's your basic
defensive position if you're speaking to
someone and you don't understand what
they're saying
that's very unsettling if you can get to
where you can at least understand what
they're saying now you're into the stage
where you're stumbling and mumbling and
trying to say something in the language
yourself and so there you have to be
prepared to go forward with whatever you
have don't worry if it's right or wrong
just go for it generally it sounds a lot
better than you think you tend to feel
that you're bad the person listening to
you I've seen this time and time again
actually is has no trouble communicates
understands and and recognizes that of
course that you're not a native speaker
but thinks you're doing a lot better
than mostly you think you're doing okay
so you have to be willing to go through
that stage now what are the things we
can do to help us along okay some people
they talk to yourself and there's
nothing wrong with that I've always
found it difficult to maintain that I
might say you know five phrases to
myself during the day but but I'm not
gonna do that as an ongoing thing I'm
not gonna stand some people stand in
front of a mirror and talk and I'm sure
that's a good thing to do but it's not
something that I could sustain writing
is an excellent thing to do since I'm
not enrolled in a language program and I
don't have assignments to hand in I
don't write because I'm quite frankly
too lazy to write but if you can if you
have the discipline I think it's an
excellent thing to do and there are many
sites including link or you can put up
some writing and people are quite happy
to come and and correct it the thing to
remember is that the the major benefit
of writing is the exercise of writing
itself but the corrections are also
useful because you could be you know
stuck in a certain pattern which is not
sort of normal usage and it pointed out
to you that no this is not normal usage
the easiest thing to do is to talk and
so now for example I oh yeah
Russian it turns out you know I've been
listening to echo muskie for six years
one of the people who appears regularly
on echo muskie is my vagin a Polsky he
is in Vancouver he's giving a talk on
Thursday to a group of Russian people I
have bought a ticket are gonna be there
I'm gonna meet one of the guys that I've
been listening to for six years so I've
been working on improving my Russian and
so I've been doing a lot of talking I
mean to speak well you have to speak a
lot so I've been signing up for
discussions with our tutors at link
Evgeny in st. Petersburg Elena in Kiev
or near Kiev and in the Ukraine and then
there's Vladimir who is a Russian who
lives in Winnipeg who's also a tutor at
Lincoln he's a great guy so I've been
talking a lot talking is good you
discover your faults I get feedback in
the form of reports or even during my
discussion and that's very good as an
example I was used to saying you know
Patamon store button will stop because
in situations where in fact in Russian
it's not because it's post cold clue
it's more like or tack karke
etc it's more like since rather than
because and in different circumstances
some of these connecting words are used
differently which Lada Mir pointed out
to me which was very useful now one way
of getting instant feedback which I
started doing and I I just mentioned it
to you and that is I had in the past
experimented with using Google Translate
to get sort of an instant translation of
what I am trying to say because if I can
struggle and try and say it myself but
it takes a while and I'm too lazy to
write but now I've got this tremendous
thing because on my Mac there is
dictation it's tremendous I got
dictation in English in French in
Spanish in German in Japanese in Korean
so first of all I don't even have to
change my keyboard to write in these
languages I just dictate it and it's you
know it prints out for me I've got the
text in front of me which is tremendous
but the way I'm now starting to use it
is I go to Google Translate and I
dictate English into the English side
and I've set it up to go from English to
Russian and then the Russian shows up
and so I just deliberately try to say
things that I would like to say of
course the Russian is a bit clumsy it's
not all natural but a lot of the key
phrases in fact are very accurate
because all of these you know machine
translation systems get better and
better at translating things based on
context I'm sure it's better for some
languages than for others but for
Russian it's really quite good so then I
take the resulting whatever I have you
know said which has been converted into
Russian I take it I imported into link I
save some of the key phrases I can still
remember what it was what it was that I
had wanted to say so in a way it's a way
of speaking or at least picking up off
on some of these key phrases that you
need to speak in other words something
that you
wanted to say in English into Russian so
I mean that's just a minor thing the
main thing is just to do a lot of
talking
so to summarize on this whole issue of
how we get to speaking some people say
you should speak from the beginning
which is fine if you have lots of time I
have an hour so a day most of it while
driving my car or exercising I can't
surround myself with people with whom I
can speak Russian so I prefer her to
focus on a lot of input activity to
build up my familiarity with the
language as I've said many times read
and save words on link and stuff like
that but now that I want to speak
Russian better ultimately I have to
speak more and when I speak I just let
it all hang out and go for it and when I
go to listen to my take on a post key on
Thursday and there will be lots of
Russians in the room and I expect to
engage in discussions on politics or
life in Canada and I will just let it
all hang out and I'll get my cases wrong
and I'll get my head whatever verbs
wrong and it won't matter and the more I
can expose myself to that kind of
situation
the sooner I will improve so there you
have it just a bit of a take on getting
to speaking thank you for listening bye
for now